- Okay, so what we're gonna
talk about today is ServiceNow,
the AI Control Tower for
business reinvention,
and AWS, the world's leading
cloud computing platform,
together, powering AI-driven workflows
on the cloud built to scale.
So let's talk about
why AWS and ServiceNow.
So there are three things:
Savings, innovation, and impact.
And first, savings.
So you can run ServiceNow
directly on AWS cloud.
How many people knew that?
This was launched last year.
One, okay.
Three, great.
And so what's great about this is,
one, you can meet your data residency,
your performance requirements,
and burn down your customer requirements,
and be connected to your cloud strategy.
This is amazing for so many customers,
they love being able to
procure through marketplace,
they love being able to decrement the PPA.
If you have a cloud strategy,
your governance compliance audit
is so much easier on one cloud
versus spread across a
zillion different clouds,
and then innovation.
So what we'll talk about today
is we have over 100 integrations
with ServiceNow products and AWS products.
They are out-of-the-box integrations.
So anytime you're using a
AWS SiteWise, AWS Connect,
Redshift, like you name it,
we have an integration
with a ServiceNow product,
and many of our customers
are super jazzed about that.
DXC is one that is using that today.
Then let's talk about impact.
So this is all about
accelerating time to value,
and we've proven deployments
with Bell Canada, with
Pearson, with DXC, with Boomi,
that customers are already
using these integrations,
are excited about how they're
impacting their end customers,
and we'll talk about that
more with the DXC interview.
So the next chapter of enterprise
transformation is here.
AI, data, and workflows
all unified on one platform
that replaces chaos with clarity.
This is the ServiceNow AI platform
where intelligence is not
added, but it is built in.
The big picture is that AI is everywhere,
and it's very fragmented.
Companies are racing to launch AI agents
and they end up with disconnected tools
and scattered data.
So ServiceNow brings that all together
on the platform you already
know, love, and trust,
and we coordinate a dynamic
network of AI agents
that turn intent into action.
It's powered by our AI orchestrator.
It's governed by AI Control Tower,
and it's your single command center
for security, compliance, and performance.
So to make AI truly transformational,
it needs connected data,
and that's where workflow
data fabric comes into play.
ServiceNow unifies all of your structured,
your unstructured, and real-time data
through Workflow Data Fabric,
which is connected to AWS.
The 100-plus integrations
that ServiceNow has on
its own outside of AWS
are integration hubs spokes.
So think about Workday,
think about DocuSign,
think about Zoom,
they're all integrated into ServiceNow.
Zero-copy connectors,
so AWS Redshift, Snowflake, Databricks,
those are live zero-copy connectors
that don't need replication,
that don't need complexity,
they're all just immediately plugged in.
And then external content creators,
so SharePoint, Slack, Confluence,
now, AI can move across every function
in every layer of your tech stack
on one platform, one
architecture, and one data model.
So if you think about it,
we have every industry covered.
We have all AI, all data, all workflows,
any cloud, and any system.
So we don't just build AI,
we put it to work for you.
So in financial services,
trust is the ultimate currency.
And in the digital age,
we are all built on speed.
So let's say a customer is
filing an insurance claim
or reports fraud, we, you, I,
don't care about the backend silos,
we just want to have results
and we wanna have the
problem fixed to resolution
as quickly as possible.
So raise your hand if you have ever felt
that an insurance claim is more miserable
than the actual accident
and have paid out-of-pocket
for an accident.
Okay, like a bunch of us,
because it's so, so miserable.
And that is something that
DXC is focused on fixing.
So this slide represents
the nervous system
of the modern financial institution,
and we're connecting AWS's intelligence
with ServiceNow's action layer.
So if we take claims automation,
which is a huge area with a ton of ROI,
in the past, a customer,
one of us who has had an accident,
would upload a PDF, for example,
and then a human would have to open it,
they'd have to read it,
they'd have to key in
all the details, and it is a very slow,
very error-prone process,
and it's extremely frustrating.
We actually have a customer
who is an insurance company,
that pays double or triple claims
on many of their insurance claims.
So they would, let's just say, you know,
pay the person that's
submitting the claim,
they would pay the mechanic,
and then they would pay the insurance,
like three different claims
and it's all backed up.
So they have, I think,
I forget exactly what the number is,
but millions and millions of dollars
that are just paid out the door
that they haven't been able to track.
These are the sort of things
that we're able to fix with ServiceNow.
So let's just use this example, right?
AWS Textract, instead of
having a human read these PDFs
that are uploaded by an insurance claim,
Textract is able to
look at all of the text,
ingest it through the AWS machine,
the policy numbers,
the amounts, the dates,
with near-perfect accuracy,
and then the data is
plugged into a workflow,
so no human has to engage with it.
That data isn't immediately
piped into ServiceNow.
We have what's called
financial services operations,
and it triggers a workflow which validates
the policy limits.
If it meets the criteria,
it automates the approval,
and the process is out of a human hands
and perfectly automated.
So this is about how are
we delivering outcomes
and no longer just
processing transactions.
So then we go into healthcare,
and this is what it looks
like in an actual hospital,
in a lab, in the back office.
On the frontend, we have
virtual patient assistants.
So we'll use Amazon Lex to
understand patient intent.
ServiceNow immediately
actions that intent,
books appointments for
people, pulls lab results,
and no human has to be in the loop.
On the admin side, staff onboarding
is an extremely
administrative painful process
for anybody who is in healthcare.
And we slash the time that it takes
to get a clinician
credentialed and compliant
by automating that data
pull from AWS databases
directly into ServiceNow workflows.
Device maintenance is actually
one of the coolest joint integrations
that we have launched.
And this is where operational
technology plus IT
has been saving lives.
So let's say an MRI machine
is in a very busy city hospital,
and it's highly used.
So every 10 minutes or every hour
it is like completely booked out.
What happens with Amazon IoT SiteWise
is that they have these
little orange devices,
you snap that onto an MRI
machine or any other machine
and it can tell whether
it's vibrating too much,
if it's hot, if it's cold,
and it will flag, in the system,
that the machine's gonna
go down in real time.
And so when this anomaly is detected,
it's not just, you know,
logged into a dashboard
that nobody looks at.
It's then flagged to,
you know, let's just say a database.
With ServiceNow, it doesn't
just go to an email like,
"Oh, Courtney, by the
way, your MRI machine
is gonna go down."
Well great, like I don't
have the machinery,
I don't have the equipment,
I don't have the tools,
I have no idea how to fix an MRI machine.
I don't know about you.
With ServiceNow, we connect
it to the right technician
with the right tools at the right time
to fix the machines so that
it is constantly running,
it is fixed before it actually goes down,
and there is no downtime.
This also happened on the shop floor
of a big car manufacturer.
So they like to have a car
come in pieces and parts
and come out the door in
one minute and 38 seconds.
We were able to bring that down
to one minute and 36 seconds,
which is actually a really
significant time savings,
because the machines and equipment
were able to go through that same process
and get fixed before they actually,
you know, they shut down
the full operations of the manufacturer.
So these are really cool
integrations out of the box
being used by our customers worldwide.
I'm gonna bring up Daniel
Stanovich from DXC.
He is the regional GM
of American Insurance,
and we're gonna talk about
ServiceNow on AWS at DXC.
- All right, this way?
- Yes.
(Daniel clears throat)
- Yeah! (clears throat)
- Thanks for being here, Dan.
- Thanks for having me.
- Such a pleasure to have you.
So why don't you just
give us a quick intro
of your background at DXC,
and then we'll get into-
- Sure.
- Your partnership
between ServiceNow, yes!
- So just a bit about
DXC insurance, 'cause
DXC is a big company,
but I'm referencing the
insurance piece of that.
So DXC insurance is the
largest insurance software
and BPS provider in the world,
by pretty much any measure.
I run a piece of that business,
which is our Life BPS that really focus
on the life and annuity insurance,
and it's really back office operations
for about 30 large life
insurance companies
in North America.
- Awesome.
And you oversee over 30
life insurance companies,
which is extremely impressive,
both technology and operations.
- Mm-hmm!
- How are ServiceNow and AWS
together helping you run and
scale that operation today?
- Yeah, so again, from
DXC insurance standpoint,
we're one of the largest
insurance users of AWS.
So we run, you know, it's
our cloud hosting platform,
we run what we call our
Assure platform on that,
which is kind of the connective tissue
that allows us to connect
into a lot of these
like heritage policy
administration systems
that we interact with.
Some of those we actually bring up
and host on the cloud, which is in AWS.
And then some of them
we just use the platform
to access with data.
And then what ServiceNow actually does,
if you think about it in layers, right,
you've got the Assure platform,
and then what ServiceNow
gives us is the ability
to orchestrate work across
those using agentic AI
and then also has a workflow
layer on top of that.
So just from, you know, a technology view,
that's how we view it.
But I think as you look
at a bigger picture,
you know, we were already
such a large user of AWS.
When we went out,
particularly my business,
I went out to look for
something to help me simplify
and automate a lot of
the business that we do
with the business process
outsourcing, right?
It's very people-oriented business today,
lot of manual process, very similar
to some of our customer
shops out in the market.
And you know, we looked at
a couple different providers
of that technology, workflow technology.
And when you think of workflow technology,
ServiceNow is really the
first that comes to your mind.
And when you look at the investments
and things that they're
making in the AI space,
particularly agentic AI,
it was kind of the
perfect marriage for us.
- What I love about some
of the ServiceNow product offerings,
like specific to industries,
is we don't build anything
unless there's true customer demand.
- Mm-hmm!
- And so we find companies
that are just saying,
"We're building this ourselves
because you don't offer it."
And then we realize, okay,
we're gonna go offer it
because there's true demand.
When you think about
transformation in insurance,
what measurable impact are you seeing
in terms of cost to serve
and productivity and claim cycle?
- Yeah, and I think just to
build on your point, right,
I mean ServiceNow brings us
that technical capability
and what we have is that
deep insurance knowledge.
- Yep.
- So we kind of paired
those two things together
and when we looked at
the businesses I support,
we actually identified
there's 127 workflows
that support a life and annuity customer.
- Wow.
- And we went through
and re-engineered those
and automated those,
you know, with the partnership
that we have with ServiceNow
and we're building
product now on ServiceNow
to support that.
And what we're actually looking at
is 30 to 40% improvement
in processing times
and same percentages in cost reduction.
So for us, it's massive
in terms of our ability
to operate more efficiently,
but then also really
increasing our productivity,
and really driving a
better customer experience
for our customer, right?
It's faster time-to-value
essentially for our customers,
which is great.
You know, you talked a lot
about a claims process,
you know, some of these claims processes
can be 60 days long to get
your life insurance claim,
which obviously when
you're in that situation,
60 days is a long time.
And so if we can find ways to
shorten that using automation
and some of the capabilities
that ServiceNow brings,
and in combination with AWS,
then we can bring that
down maybe to 10, 15 days,
which would be a massive
improvement for these companies
and for the individuals affected.
- That's awesome.
So you are building smart
apps with ServiceNow.
Can you talk about that?
- Yeah, smart apps again,
the way I would kind of...
Yes, we are building smart apps.
Smart apps are kind of broken down pieces
of workflows, right?
So if you think about a workflow
as a big end-to-end
process, but what we...
You know, and to implement some of that
can take some time, right?
We're finding that out
as we're implementing,
you know, our Assure
BPM into my shop today,
which is kind of the
full end-to-end workflow,
all 127 workflows I talked about.
But what smart apps are is
actually discrete pieces of value
that we can deliver quicker, right?
So if you're an insurance company,
what if I can just go and automate
your submission process, right,
your application submission process.
So I'm not doing the entire end-to-end,
what we would call new business process,
just automating that piece,
which will drive a lot
of efficiency, right?
So if you're getting thousand
of applications a month
and those are manually provided
so they're actually
written on applications,
if we can automate reading
of those applications
and the processing of those applications
to bring speed to value to you quicker,
that's really what a smart app is.
So it's allows us to kind of
incrementally deliver value
a lot faster, so in weeks
versus maybe months, right,
which is for us the real value.
- And how are you
prioritizing those smart apps?
There's 127 workflows.
- Yeah.
- How many smart apps
are there and how do you prioritize-
- You know what it is, it's
actually customer feedback
that's driving a lot of that.
So we obviously interact with
our customers quite a bit
and we just actually had a customer week,
which is a user conference
down in October in Charleston
and we got a lot of good feedback there.
And you pretty much drill
into a couple key topics
pretty quick, right?
It's gonna be claims,
it's gonna be some of the
submission process I talked about
that are gonna drive some
of those pain points.
And so that's really what's driving it,
is the customer demand at this point.
- So DXC is customer zero,
both ServiceNow on AWS
and of the smart apps.
- Yeah.
- How are you implementing them
internally in your business,
and as you start to offer
them to external customers,
what are you learning?
- Yeah, so it's interesting.
So again, we started our partnership
with ServiceNow about a year ago,
and you know, again, we've
obviously been developing
a lot of our kind of what we wanted to do,
but we initially started
that we were gonna replace
my existing workflow
system and capabilities
with the ServiceNow capabilities
and one fell swoop.
Like you run into in the marketplace,
there's a lot of technical
challenge to that
and it takes longer
than we would've liked,
especially for customer zero.
And so we're still doing that,
but in the meantime,
what we've actually pivoted to now
is doing more of a smart app strategy
where we can say we can drip in
some of this capability a little
bit faster with smart apps.
And so now, I'm actually able
to deliver value quicker,
and again, I'm replicating
what we're gonna do
for our customers, right?
So I can say, "Hey, we've
done this in my shop
and we've automated the claims
submission process, right,
we've seen these results,
you know, and we can do it
for you in weeks as well
and just spin that product up
while we're working on getting
that whole end-to-end process in place.
So I think it's a massive thing
just in terms of being
able to deliver value
to customers quicker in areas
that are really causing them pain.
- Awesome.
So last question, if we
look ahead to the future,
how do you see the combination
of AWS, ServiceNow, DXC Insurance,
transforming the future
of insurance operations?
- Yeah, I mean we look at it
as the perfect combination.
I mean these are the
largest players really
in their respective spaces, right?
AWS from a cloud hosting standpoint,
ServiceNow from a workflow technology,
agentic AI standpoint,
then DXC being the leader
in insurance software
and business process outsourcing.
For us, it was just like,
it's the perfect
combination of organizations
to solve this problem in the industry,
which again is really
is a transformational focus for us, right?
I mean insurance companies,
especially life insurance companies
have been doing the same
thing for decades, right?
They've made their problems
worse over decades, right?
They've bought all these
different technologies,
they've kind of took process
and added more process on top of that,
and where you end up is a lot of
what we like to call
capability debt, right,
which is, you know, you
take all your technical debt
and your processing debt
and add that together
and that gives you this capability debt.
So it really hinders the
organization's ability
to grow and progress.
And so if we can eliminate a lot of that
by putting in some of this
automation and agentic AI,
I think that's gonna make
a world of difference.
- Awesome.
Thanks so much for being here,
thanks for being a partner.
And for those of you who wanna do
a breakout session, like
round table, with Dan,
there will be an opportunity
later on this week.
- Great, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, so now we're bringing
up Ann Culver, I believe.
If I can change the slides.
Ann Culver from AWS.
- Hi, everyone.
So as Courtney mentioned,
ServiceNow on AWS has been available
since January of last year,
and we have a fully integrated stack.
So basically a mirrored stack
from what ServiceNow does
on their own data centers.
But the advantage with
AWS is it integrates
with all the other AWS
services that we have to offer.
So I'm not gonna read
through these slides,
but let's see if I can get
this so that you can see it.
So we have spent a lot of
time trying to make sure
that we've got the right integration.
So as you look at your
orchestrated workflows
across the enterprise,
those interface with the services
that you know and love and use from AWS.
And I'm not gonna go
into any of these in great detail.
So just so that you can see obviously,
one of the things we've been
focusing on together is AI,
making sure that ServiceNow is able
to provide AWS models
through Amazon Bedrock
as part of Now Assist,
so that integration has been complete.
But it allows you to choose your own model
and use it across the ServiceNow platform
running on top of AWS obviously,
so you can see that there.
One of the integrations
that we recently announced
is AI Control Tower
with Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
I don't know if any of you
are familiar with AgentCore.
Yes, hopefully.
It is going to be something
you hear a lot about this week,
but it is Amazon's basically entry point
into the AI world and agentic AI.
So it's meant to be sort of
your one-stop entry point,
and that integration
again with ServiceNow,
enables your agentic workflow
across the enterprise.
So getting rid of all that siloed data,
making sure everything
is working seamlessly across the platform.
I think S3 was mentioned
in another meeting I was in earlier today.
But S3 is becoming,
and has been obviously,
a big source of data
where we have a lot of
partners including ServiceNow,
that are looking to
enable customer S3 data
across what they're doing
from a SaaS platform perspective.
Workflow data fabric with
S3 tables integration
allows you to do that.
So again, I'm not gonna read this
'cause I'm not an
engineer, but there it is.
The level of integrations is growing.
So we've been working with ServiceNow
for a number of years
on the integration front
way before ServiceNow
on AWS was available.
So you can see across the entire AWS stack
where we've got integrations here,
very, very extensive.
And if you're interested in learning more
about any of these,
please come by the ServiceNow booth,
we've got folks who can dive deep
on each one of these with you.
Another level of integration with IoT,
I'll give y'all a moment
'cause I'm not gonna
walk through this one.
But you can follow the bouncing ball.
And at ServiceNow
Knowledge we talked about,
or announced zero-copy connectors
with workflow data fabric.
So you can see here how it's
meant to connect data silos,
obviously decreased spend,
increased performance,
help with security, simplified compliance,
and obviously control your secure access.
And again, we've got folks at the booth
who can walk through this with you.
Oh, and that's it.
Okay, we're going to move
on to a panel discussion,
and I'd love to invite Courtney
and John back to the stage.
Courtney, are you joining
or am I doing this?
I'm doing this, okay, John, come on up.
John Licata, everyone, from ServiceNow.
(audience applauding)
- Hello.
- Hello!
John and I do a lot of of fun discussions
out there in the world these days.
So we're gonna talk a little bit
about how AI and agentic is converging,
and what that means for folks
using the ServiceNow platform,
as well as some of the advancements
that we're seeing out there in the world.
So let's start with maybe
a technical foundation.
We're hearing a lot about orchestration
and collaboration among AI agents.
How do you see AWS and ServiceNow
approaching multi-agent orchestration?
- Yeah, so I'm glad you said multi-agent
because we live in a world right now
where people talk about
an agent as a singular,
but we need to start
thinking about expanding that
and teams of agents working together.
So with Bedrock and you have access
to a lot of different AI
models, which is wonderful,
but I think we actually have to figure out
how can we have like that
single pane of glass,
how can we access to understand,
how could you look at
maybe the AI Control Tower
of ServiceNow to help govern,
put provisions in place, put parameters.
You don't want to have agentic anarchy,
we need rules.
- Mm-hmm!
- And I think sometimes that's lost
in today's talk about agentic AI
is that we need to put
parameters and guardrails up.
Pretty soon we're gonna
start to see audits happen
when it comes to AI, it's inevitable.
So I think one of the good things
about how we are thinking
about it together
is how can we look at how
you are leveraging AI models
with AWS and how can you bring
the enterprise lens in from ServiceNow?
So the whole better
together angle, I think,
is definitely something that you've heard
probably time and time
again the last several days.
But it's true, because I think
we bring the enterprise lens
to the agentic opportunity in front.
But I think that you
have the cloud expertise
that together, I think
that kind of expands
your horizon of what you
can do with the agents.
But I also think another
thing that's important to note
is as we're thinking about
the expansion of AI agents,
there still has to be humans in the loop.
We keep forgetting us, we
keep forgetting people.
So we need to figure out
when there's more serious decision making
that needs to take place,
maybe the agents do certain tasks,
but there still should
be a human in the loop
for the more complicated.
And so I think the orchestration
has to be across different landscape.
And by landscape, I mean AWS cloud,
we both deal with on-prem
and SaaS companies,
and there's a lot of different players,
and each one has their
own governance model.
So how can we help each other
by bringing this a amazing
end-to-end visibility
and transparency that's
super needed today?
And I think that's the benefit
of the AI Control Tower
and how we're already starting to see
a locking real value.
And I think that's something
too is let's get value
and not just talk about
agents doing X, Y, Z.
People need to see results,
but as you're building these solutions,
it should be something that governance is
in part of your, you know, your thinking
of how you're gonna advance your models
and your workflows.
We need governance, and
I think that's something
that is an industry sort
of push to do together,
but something I'm excited
that we were doing together.
- We've talked before
about the intersection
of innovation and governance.
Maybe provide some thoughts around that.
- I mean so much is
happening in the world today.
I mean you have NIST regulations,
you have DORA in Europe
with operational resiliency.
So many different things that
we need to take into account.
And I think that that expands
the difficulty, I think,
of what to do with agents.
If you give agents certain
leeway to do a task,
when do you take back the provision
to do the task, the security?
Do you do it when the task is done,
when the job is complete?
Like there's so many different
agents along the way,
it's not one agent doing the whole job.
You can have teams of agents
doing pieces of the job.
And so I think that's
the interesting thing
is how do you maintain
your channel checks?
And again, human in the loop is important,
but I can't emphasize enough
this idea of AI audits
and how we need to start thinking
not just of how workflows exist today.
We need to reimagine workflows.
And I think that's one of
the more amazing things
when we speak and our teams come together
is we start to think about let's turn
the current workflows on their head,
where can we start to reimagine
the art of the possible?
I mean, art of the possible is something
that got us all into this,
but what does that actually mean?
I think orchestrating that
and making sure that
we can lead by example
by delivering governance when it's needed,
but also bring value to the table.
I think we can't underscore enough
that it's not just about saying
the agents are doing X, Y, and Z.
People wanna see value.
- Mm-hmm, today's AI
agents are often limited
by scalability and coordination issues
due to lots of different reasons.
Fragmented data pipelines
is one of those problems
that ServiceNow is solving.
Maybe you can illustrate
that a little bit.
- I'll give an example, Courtney earlier,
she talked about finance,
and she gave in some information
related to the fragmentation
around finance.
I spent 20 years of my
career on Wall Street,
there is such a need for
regulation oversight,
and that's happening
whether you have currencies,
digital, stable coins,
a lot that's happening in the world today.
So with finance, especially,
there's a lot of fraud,
and I think identity management and fraud
also need to take place.
But also now, think about it
in the world that we're
discussing right now with agents,
there could be agent fraud.
We can't just take for face value
that the agent's gonna do the task
and that's how we need
to take it as trust.
So trust is something that's inherent,
but in the financial industry,
it's something that's a huge concern,
that you have a lot of
agents doing transactions,
who's governing the authority
to distribute capital?
That's why think it's important
to have the human in the loop.
But Wall Street is one
of the biggest areas
and pharma is another one
thinking about, you know,
personalized medicine and what
you can do to deliver that
and people's rights and personal data,
and you know, HIPAA violations.
So I think what you're seeing right now
is a look into what could we do,
but what can we do ethically
and bring responsible AI
into the agentic equation.
- Hmm, from that perspective,
and you look at the engineering
task in front of us, right,
there was something that
I read the other day
about the memory scale
that we've gotta now,
start looking at as well with AI.
Has ServiceNow looked
into that a little bit?
- So I think it's always
important to, first of all,
I have two young kids, so
memory is becoming something
I don't have much of these days,
but I think, you know what
we're trying to think of,
imagine a world where each
of us has hundreds of agents.
So I think it's great to use GenAI
for certain summarization capabilities
and do certain tasks,
but we have to be our own creative engine.
And I think that's something
I'm personally excited about
as we work together is I
think we bring the best
out of each other, AWS and ServiceNow.
But I think, first of all,
intelligence is only as
good as you can use it.
So it's great to have
the visibility into data,
but if you don't know how
to interpret the data,
you're at a disadvantage.
If you don't know how to put the data,
I guess at use it at the
right time in the right place,
you're at a disadvantage.
You know, I was talking
to someone the other day,
talking about intelligence
when it comes to finance,
if you had models give everybody
the same sort of information,
would the stock market just be flat?
And I took a moment to think about this,
looking back into my
earlier parts of my career
and think about it, there's
a lot of investment banks
that have had, you know,
program trading around
for over two decades.
Some hedge funds lose money,
some hedge funds make money.
It's how you interpret the data.
So I think when it comes
to the future of agents,
we have to start to bring in
contextuality into this too
'cause we all consume
information differently.
So just to say here's the blanket data,
we're all gonna have the same results,
I think is not the right frame of mind.
We need to think about the
contextual nature of agents,
and that's gonna take time.
But this is part of the research
that has to be brought forward,
is how do we train
agents to think like us?
And it's not so easy to say that,
you know, I think we need to figure out
what we really want the agents to do,
and they might know certain
pieces of information,
and I think this is where
we're gonna see an evolution.
We don't need to give that
agent everything about us,
or in every part of
the business ecosystem,
they need to do one thing
and one thing right,
repetitively and at scale.
And I think that's where
you're gonna start to see,
you know, specialist the way
we have in our own human jobs.
We have specialists who
do different things.
Agents are gonna become specialists,
and I think so intelligence
only as good as you can use it,
and I look forward to seeing
how we evolve that together.
- So smarter resource allocation-
- Sure.
- Right?
Many enterprises are still guessing
how many agents or humans
to allocate towards a project.
From your standpoint, sorry,
that was my ringer too,
so I'm like, "Wait, what?"
How are AWS and ServiceNow
working together
to bring data-driven
benchmarking to agents
and human resource planning?
What does that mean for
productivity and budget?
- I think it's a marvel
when you start to think
about how many agents do you
actually need to do a job.
I think it's a complicated question
when we refer to agents,
it's taken for granted,
is it seven agents, is it 20 agents,
is it three humans, is it five humans?
So I think right now
it's been a guessing game
and that's hurt people who
have allocated money towards AI
seeking faster returns
because they actually are not allocating
the proper amount, and what
the beauty of our relationship
is to explore what could that look like.
And so it's exciting to know
that we're both committed
to exploring that together.
Because I think if we have
the benchmarking put in place,
it can allow you as
developers and engineers
the ability to make better decisions
with prototyping too
and see what works and what doesn't.
And right now, that's a guessing game,
and we all know that we have
to show tangible results.
So I think benchmarking
is something that I look
forward to in the new year,
which is not that far away,
both of us coming forward together
with academic partnerships
because I think that we
need to ground everything
that we're discussing in research.
And one of the beauties
of our relationship
is we don't go for the hype headline.
And I do think that the
industry has been hurt
by a lot of headlines.
And for us, I think,
as ServiceNow and AWS have come together,
we're trying to figure out
how can we actually
support what we're saying.
So I like the methodical
approach of taking research
and turning research into validity,
and validity into action that
we both could benefit from.
So that's been a wonderful thing.
So they say, "What happens
in Vegas stays in Vegas."
I'm happy that that goes beyond the world
because we're doing some
bright things together.
- Well, it's a great segue.
We are working together
towards a academic partnership,
ServiceNow, AWS, and a
well-known institution
to experiment more with technology
so that we've got some benchmarking.
Maybe walk the audience through
why we're doing this together
and what the outcome
we're expecting to get.
- Yeah, I mean this is the fun part
of the conversation for me-
- Yeah, this is, yeah.
- So I think it's interesting
because AI is fantastic,
it also has limitations.
And so as we are thinking about
how do we help you
become more future-ready
as you are delivering
solutions to your customers
and in your businesses,
we are looking actively at the role
of quantum computing plus AI.
So quantum plus AI and the role of agents.
There's a lot of
opportunities that we foresee
that the agent ecosystem
is only beginning.
There's a lot to happen,
and again, teams of agents
operating in different landscapes,
again across SaaS companies,
on-prem businesses, as
well as in the cloud,
and we need to figure out how
we can manage this better,
how we can attack more difficult problems.
So quantum will absolutely
not be used for everything,
but we do believe there is a future
where certain business
cases make sense to explore.
And the endeavor that we have with AWS
is to look at the use cases,
see what makes the most sense,
again grounded in research and validity,
but bring it forward in a way
that we are confident
that it can help people.
And I think that goes
back to our mutual roots
of helping people and putting
AI to work for people.
So quantum plus AI, it's exciting,
look at the role of simulation,
what we might be able to do
in natural disaster relief
or in the financial space.
But beyond, look at personalized medicine,
things that we might be able to look at,
individuals versus the mass.
And so we feel even with
supply chain and logistics,
I mean, who would've
thought a few years ago
there would've been a vessel
stuck in the Suez Canal
and it crippled global
trade for many days.
We need to start anticipating more
and having that modeling
more advanced digital twins.
So we do feel like there's a component
that needs to be looked at
for better decision making,
and we hope that that that enterprise lens
with a quantum plus AI story is beneficial
to those using AWS as well as ServiceNow.
- So on that quantum computing track,
how do you see quantum computing
shaping industry moving
forward, our industries?
- Yeah, I mean I think,
well, first of all,
I mean look at, and if you're based here
in the United States,
there's mandates out of the White House,
there's new regulations out of NIST.
Financial companies will
have to be reporting more
on quantum readiness.
Companies that we've been speaking to
have already said that the way
people report on Wall Street
for sustainability initiatives
may soon have to report quantum readiness.
And we are excited that we published,
not too long ago, several months ago,
the first quantum readiness
story from ServiceNow.
And we are excited because
it's grounded in something
that is near term, the
ServiceNow Vault team
in Q1 of next year,
post-quantum cryptography.
PQC is classical base, but nevertheless,
it's a journey, we have to start there.
So I think how it shapes is forcing people
to think about industry is different,
but also again, elevating
the governance piece.
What can we do to help people,
help companies safeguard data?
'Cause right now there is
the harvest now, decrypt later phenomenon
that impacts all businesses.
So what can we do to start
thinking about that more rapidly?
And so I think moving from PQC
and advancing it into ways
that could become global standards,
you know, I think that's where, you know,
us getting involved together
in the public sector
and as well in the industry,
I just think it's an amazing opportunity
to think about what the
global world could look like
in this new paradigm that I think is,
again, looking at agentic
AI is still very new.
- Mm-hmm!
- And we need governance.
I can't say that enough to all of you
as you're building your solutions,
we need to figure out how
a way to bring truth in.
'Cause right now there's
a lot of hallucinations
that need to be revisited too.
So, you know, the role of
quantum would be something
that we think as an accelerator to AI.
I had said earlier, quantum plus AI,
'cause it is an accelerator.
AI is great, but it could do better,
and we think quantum
could be a really good remedy for that.
- So how do we get our workforce ready
for that combination, for AI plus quantum?
- Well, first, I think enablement is key.
I mean, I think, you
know, in many businesses,
I think it's important to
put together AI enablement.
But I think as we have in ServiceNow,
we actually are dedicating time
for quantum enablement in 2026.
I think it's important to do both.
You know, not everyone's
is a quantum physicist
or they're trained in classical AI
and it's hard to bring those people out.
But there's such an appetite
we're finding internally
for engineers that we have in AI
to venture into the quantum side.
And so there are courses, certifications,
things that we've even discussed,
maybe even doing some
certifications together.
But this is a journey,
this is not something
that you're gonna do this by January 15th
and you're gonna have the answer.
It is a journey, but
we feel very confident
that it's the right path to go on.
- If you could give one piece of advice
to the builders in the audience,
how can they start engaging
with ServiceNow and AWS on co-innovation?
- Yeah, well, good question.
So I'm part of the future
team for ServiceNow.
And I think it's important to...
You know, it has to be bidirectional.
It can't be us coming
always to you and saying,
"Hey, we have a solution."
We wanna know what the problem is.
We already hear from you
to say this has been a pain point.
Hearing from customers,
so jointly hearing from customers
to say how we might be able to help you
is definitely paramount.
I think that we need to understand
is what can we do from
a pilot perspective.
You know, you have to ask leadership,
is it okay to have a window of time?
'Cause I think we need time,
whether we dedicate
three months to attacking
a specific problem or a
year in a research study.
I think that's important.
Again, we need to ground in validity.
So I think where we can start to see this
is pick up a phone and
email to you and me,
and see like where are you finding
that there's an opportunity
to leverage innovation.
And I think we have innovation forums,
we invite people to EBCs
where we focus on innovation workshops
and kind of get to, you know,
the crux of the problem.
Sometimes people come in with one problem
and they realize in the
grand scheme of things
it was very short-term.
So if we're talking about
being in a world of horizons,
we need to start thinking about,
you know, short, medium, and long term.
But horizon three is not
five years away anymore.
The speed of innovation
has happened so fast
that we need to figure out a way
to accelerate innovation.
So that patience is getting shorter,
and I think we have to
deliver the results.
So jointly, one thing
that you said earlier,
just to say about, you know,
back to the enablement,
you need to get support from leadership,
you need to have a cross org committee
focused on innovation,
focused on quantum plus AI,
focused on AI.
I think a lot of people
work on projects and silos,
and I think that one of the beauties
of how we can work together
is help break the silos.
So we do that first internally cross org
and then cross company,
like we've been doing.
I think it's been successful
as we started exploring
possibilities with the
role of quantum plus AI,
we pushed each other behind closed doors.
And I think that that's my ask of you,
it's you need the cross team alignment.
'Cause we often find that
that's such a hindrance for innovation.
And also the next earnings report
shouldn't be the reason why
you move innovation forward.
We need to think more of more
agility but also longevity.
- Mm-hmm, thank you.
We have a few minutes for some
questions from the audience
if anybody has a question for John.
Anyone?
- I can't even see,
it's like...
- Yeah, it is very bright.
All right, well, I'll ask you one.
So one of the things
that we've talked about
in this whole quantum world
is kind of like where to start, right?
So I think a lot of organizations
had that same thing with AI,
where do you start?
And we have joint customers
that are still trying to figure that out.
So as organizations are looking
at where to start with AI
and starting their journey,
how do they start looking at quantum
and starting that journey?
- I think you have to see
where you're already facing
pain points in your business
and seeing where you're already
having difficulty with AI.
Some of the more complex computations
will require an opportunity
to look at quantum.
But I think that having the ability
to recognize what's already
working and what's not
is really important as step one..
I think it's important
to think about putting quantum to work.
I think there was a slide earlier
that Courtney had up of AI
plus data plus workflows,
and you have to understand
that is there an opportunity
for AI plus data plus
quantum AI workflows.
So a lot of it is to test and try,
but I think you have to
start by understanding
what is your current environment
and where are you seeing gaps.
And like I said earlier,
quantum will not solve everything,
but we are leading with AI
and trying to fill gaps with quantum,
and that's the way I think you need
to look into your own
organization to fill the gaps.
- Hmm, agreed.
So at AWS, we're seeing organizations,
a lot of healthcare
organizations using quantum
just because of the
computational, you know, nature.
How do you see, I know you
talked about the workforce
a little bit earlier today,
but what types of people
now do we need to employ
to start thinking about the problems
we don't even know we have yet?
- Look, I have a eight-year-old
son who's coding right now.
I used to go outside and go play soccer,
he's building Minecraft
and all these things.
The next generation is coming
up very different than us.
Kids today are already using AI in school.
I think data science is really important.
I think learning different,
playing around with different models
is also very important.
ChatGPT is not an AI strategy.
And so I think what we need to use
all the different availability
of models that are out there,
and I think exposing kids to this,
I think is really important.
But as the kids become the next leaders,
we ourselves need to figure out
what do we want to do with this.
So I think, you know,
there's a lot of academic institutions
that offer free certifications
around quantum computing,
I think that's also very important.
You and I have had the opportunity
to speak at a couple of
academic institutions,
and there is a willingness
to open up different paths
with like leveraging students in college
and bring them into your company.
So I think that's a new avenue,
internships of course.
But I think that there's
just an opportunity right now
to look into math, because, you know,
there will be limitations.
You're talking about zeros and ones
and you're talking about nature.
So it's quite different.
So I just think that we need...
I feel like people say you need
to study this and just this,
and I feel like you
should study everything
'cause you learn one model
and next week a new one comes out.
It's so hard, it's like, you know,
Charlie Brown when he kicks the football
and Lucy moves the goalpost.
That's how AI is today.
Like we're just we're
getting too comfortable
putting one set of strategies in place.
So I think with quantum too,
so with both parallel,
I think it's an interesting
dynamic to continue to learn,
but also to test things.
And I think to that is, you know,
engineering is gonna have
a very bright future,
you know, for decades to come.
- You touched on it just a second ago,
but model choice is confusing, fantastic,
difficult to navigate, a
lot of different things.
What's ServiceNow's
approach to model choice?
- So we are agnostic,
and similar approach to how...
So AI is very agnostic in that,
and I think that's one of the beauties
of how we work together
because quite honestly,
so are you.
But I think it's for us
is to try to figure out the orchestration
that's needed still in being agnostic.
But I think that there's, you know,
different models today have
also governance issues.
Like there's European models
that have quite different
information as they do here.
And if you actually try to solve a problem
and you gave the same problem
to five different models,
you would be surprised
at what you get back,
and how maybe how different
the answers actually are.
So don't take what the
models give as face value
and make a business decision
on just what the model inputs.
But I think that one of the things
that you can do is start benchmarking,
and benchmarking the success
and also benchmarking who's using what.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why the AI Control Tower from
ServiceNow is very valuable
because it gives that window
into who's using the models,
and what's the benefit of the models.
And you could start, so
I think parsing the data,
and it goes back to
understanding the data,
but models are super interesting.
Certain models are good
for certain things,
and I think that's one of the things,
the enablement piece, has
to help people understand,
is that good for you?
And it might not be.
- Which poses some very
interesting questions
when you look at an organization
and how they're going to
start implementing AI,
and who's in charge of choosing models.
I don't know if you have looked
into how that governance piece is.
It's a slightly different problem.
- I don't think that we haven't been told
like do this, not that.
I think there has been
a definite gravitation
towards trying new things
and bringing them forward.
And if you have a case
for trying something new
that we don't have access to,
I think it's something
that the executive team
is very receptive to that.
But I think, you know, make
the business case for models,
I think is very important too.
People use models, and
to your point earlier,
they just assume it's the right model.
Now we're talking about
how we came together
is the enterprise and the cloud..
Enterprise models, some
models are better than others,
and some models, you may
just get the job done.
And I think some of
that's trial and error.
I mean, I was just saying this
'cause I know one of my developers
is in the audience right now.
I mean I use Claude
and I've been using prototyping
just as a tool for myself to prove ideas.
It's quite valuable,
it's kind of interesting to see that.
So it's nice that we
actually now have Claude
inside of ServiceNow.
So I think sometimes when you make a case
for certain models being beneficial,
I think you'll have good access to them.
- I think one of the things that AWS
that we are trying to
help guide customers on
is how to budget around AI
'cause it's a new territory.
Can you talk a little bit
about when you're looking
at sort of this overall AI
strategy for an organization
and looking at the workflows
that would require the
most attention first,
and that's very subjective obviously,
how should organizations
look at, you know,
the right model versus
cost versus governance?
- Yeah, I mean, well, look,
cost is definitely gonna
be high on the equation.
But as I said earlier,
certain models are different
for the enterprise than they are for,
you know, normal use.
Nevertheless, I think
how you're gonna do it
is tie the models to strategy.
And I think that's another thing
that's been missing too,
is people been using AI
but actually not tying
it to corporate strategy.
And I think as people start to bring
AI and strategy closer together,
I think you're gonna find results.
And it's interesting 'cause at ServiceNow,
we have our CFO,
the corporate strategy team
actually reports to her.
So think about this for a second.
So spending into AI, financial results,
strategic initiatives,
they're tied together.
And I think you're gonna see more of that,
and by that I mean bringing
AI closer to strategy.
'Cause I think that we
need to start proving this,
'cause it shouldn't be a blank check.
And I think that's been the approach
for the last two years is we
had the OpenAI ChatGPT moment
and people just started writing a check
just because they wanted
AI in their brochure.
But nevertheless, I think putting it
when we have tangible results
that you can actually
support customer validations,
like we had DXC well here earlier.
I think having customers actually saying
that we've tried it and it worked,
you'll get the bigger budget for AI.
But I think we need more proof,
and I think that's gonna take time.
But I like the notion of bringing AI
and strategy closer
together because ultimately,
I think the benefit is super high,
and I think that's one of the reasons
why strategically we've come together
because we know that
there's a bigger story here,
but we've aligned strategy
with the spending,
and I think that's maybe a lesson
to think about after this.
- Yeah, we've seen a
number of organizations
report increased cost savings
by using AI even though there is
a different spend calculation
that goes along with it.
And I would say, you know, at AWS,
a number of the organizations
that we've worked with
first and foremost sort
of early on in all of this
tackled really big use cases early on.
And I think we've talked a lot about,
"Err, don't do that, start smaller,
and kind of work your way up."
What's your advice for organizations?
- I think you've heard me
actually say this expression before,
but if there's any baseball
fans in the audience,
if you hit a single every day,
you get into the Hall of Fame,
you do not need to hit a home run.
And I think that's been,
I think, a misconception
about how to use AI, is you
need to show grand results
Hit the base hit, show the results,
build upon those results,
and I think you'll have a lot more
of strategic outcomes
that you can be proud of.
- In sort of last question for you,
what's the downside to all of this?
Like what advice would you give?
Like what's to watch? (mumbles)
Sorry, what to watch out for?
- I mean I think I alluded to it earlier
is I think sometimes we use these models
and we take them as credible
answers, credible advice.
And I think that we still
need the human in the loop,
and I think we need to
model future workflows
with more human involvement.
And I think that that's something
that is gonna take a lot
of rolling up our sleeves
to figure out the place.
'Cause it's not just
how work is done today.
And earlier I mentioned
like re-imagining work,
and I think that's something
that I would love to think about more.
We bring out the best of each other
'cause behind closed doors,
we are pushing the problem set.
And I think that's something
that I think people should start to do
is what is the compliance,
what's the topic of this
panel of governance?
Like that's gonna be part
of like what is going
to be pulled through.
So, I mean, I think, you know,
if you can meet the upcoming regulations,
like don't look just past one
quarter or second quarter,
there's a lot humming.
The fact that quantum is
part of a conversation
with AWS and ServiceNow,
you can see that we're
taking this super seriously.
So I think as you're
planning for what comes next,
don't forget to where we are,
and responsible AI is built on trust.
And that's one of the
hallmarks of our relationship.
- Yeah, and I think getting
people used to using it
in the first place, right, too.
- Trial and error.
- Yeah, trial and error.
John, thank you so much
for your time today.
Thank you all for joining us today.
Thank you for being at "AWS re:Invent".
Hope you have a wonderful week.
(audience applauding)